America's evil Top Hat Canada is going
after our friend Jordan Peterson
why are they going after Peterson
well they're trying to censor him a
Canadian uh court is backing this
psychologist organization the College of
psychologists of Ontario which has
embraced radical
gonna have to bleep this one on YouTube
guys radical
Theory and because Jordan understands
that men are not women uh they're
they're trying to take his his license
away they're trying to go after him the
the Ontario superior court of justice
has ordered Jordan to pay 25 Grand to
the College of psychologists and upheld
the order that he go through a social
media education program this Jordan
Peterson he's going totally insane
he is stating a basic truth why are they
going after him they're going after
Jordan because he is effective they're
going after Jordan because unlike most
people who come from the academy most
people even who are clinical
psychologists Jordan is reaching
millions and millions and millions of
people
uh they can't have that because he's
reaching millions and millions and
millions of people and telling them
really basic things about how to improve
their lives
we we make fun of because he says make
your bed you know clean up your room and
we we laugh about this
the funny thing is that such basic
advice needs to be stated out loud
that's how confused our culture is and
the libs don't like that so they're
they're trying to make an example of him
trying to they're trying to not just go
after Jordan who it doesn't really
affect I don't think Jordan is taking
all that many clients these days he's
traveling around the world giving
speeches and writing books and doing
movies
this is this is a message for the other
psychologists who dare to contradict the
prevailing orthodoxies on sexual
ideology
Jordan Jordan doesn't need the money
but most other clinical psychologists do
so it's a warning message to them
why why are people turning to
psychologists so much these days why do
people tuning into Jordan so much people
are anxious
okay you're so anxious that now
according to the Wall Street Journal
nearly three patients in 100 who entered
a Health Care Facility
left with a newly diagnosed anxiety
disorder that rate is higher than cancer
or diabetes According to truveta which
is a healthcare and analytics company
40 of people who take the most popular
antidepressants for anxiety disorders
because this is what the psychiatrists
do
not the psychologists who do cognitive
behavioral stuff we're talking about the
drug dealers who just say oh you don't
like your mom here get high take this
drug and then you'll feel better 40 of
people who take those drugs
receive little benefit according to this
study
some need to stop the medications
because they have awful side effects
and by the way that 40 percent number
who receive little benefit that means
that there's 60 who get some benefit
that sixty percent number of those is
probably inflated because research
suggests that some of the benefits of
antidepressants are just Placebo so
people pop the pill and they think that
they're supposed to feel better and they
do so even to say that 60 of people get
some benefit from these drugs probably
overstating it why are people so
anxious
whole host of reasons the obviously the
most fundamental reason when we're
talking about any aspect of the human
condition is going to be a religious
problem because
religion forms the the basis of our
belief about everything everything flows
from there our views of anthropology our
views of epistemology our views of
morality our views of politics
everything comes from the fundamental
question
who's God is there a god is there
meaning what does it mean to be what is
even ontology what does it mean to be
comes comes from theology so that's the
first one but then there are just these
political issues which is things are
unsettled I don't think you need to go
Pie in the Sky really abstract to to get
to the heart of why we're anxious now
we're anxious because our our entire way
of life is unsettled we're anxious
because the ruling class can arrest the
opposition leader and his lawyers and
his friends just for supporting him
we're anxious because the meaning of
marriage has completely been exploded
we're anxious because we're our economy
is completely up in the air and we can't
reliably make any money and even if we
can reliably make money most people are
going to be saddled with a ton of debt
with no end in sight
we're we're anxious because inflation is
going through the roof and we can't
afford eggs especially I can't afford
eggs because my wife wants to buy 50
eggs where they have three college
degrees we we are saddled with mountains
and mountains of debt we've got
increasing turmoil around the world the
potential of World War III no wonder
people are
anxious
this is
this is a problem of not being settled
and some things fly out of our control
we talked to the top of the show about
Crossing the Rubicon and at a certain
point you you feel as though your your
future is up to chance
but we can settle certain things we
didn't need to explode the meaning of
marriage
we don't need to apply our country with
all sorts of Vice that turns us all into
Maniacs like drugs and porn and all the
rest of it we don't we don't need to
open up our borders and let foreigners
come into the tune of three and a half
four and a half million a year
we don't need to let criminals off the
hook we don't need to do any of that
okay this is why I I often extol the
virtues of a tiny little Nation over in
central eastern Europe I would be
Hungary what Hungary has done hungary's
going through a lot of turmoil 45 years
of communist
oppression
Hungary has made a very concerted effort
to settle things to settle things in a
way that is quite traditional that
people can rely on they just celebrated
the anniversary of Saint Stephen the day
the beginning of their country founded
on the the crown of Saint Stephen
over a thousand years ago
we
we are not going to fix the anxiety
pandemic the real pandemic
by continuing to innovate and reinvent
the wheel and invent 10 more sexual
identities and
rewrite the Constitution and rewrite all
of our laws we're going to
fix the anxiety epidemic here is the
best advice you don't need to spend a
billion dollars on your psychiatrist I'm
going to give you the advice right now
we're going to fix it by being normal
just Endeavor to be normal and do normal
things will help you quite a lot hey
movie star Mike it's the Chuck Meister
I've got a question about your favorite
movie Me Myself and Irene which I just
watched for the first time a few weeks
ago recently on music Monday you
mentioned a scene from The Blues
Brothers which is actually my favorite
movie because it's an absurdist comedy
with Catholic undertones set near where
I grew up I was wondering though why is
Me Myself and Irene your favorite movie
other than it being an absurdist comedy
with Catholic undertones set near where
you grew up I want a Roger ebert-esque
response because this film was much
raunchier than I expected for such a
Trad person like yourself love the show
thanks thank you great question it is
very raunchy I I wouldn't recommend it I
mean I think I saw when I was about nine
years old or 10 years old but I wouldn't
necessarily recommend it for
young audiences but to your point you
say well it's this absurdist movie with
Catholic undertones you might even just
say with
traditional wholesome undertones oddly
enough for a movie that uses all sorts
of vulgar language and has all sorts of
vulgar images in it It's oddly wholesome
the point of the movie is pretty
wholesome it's very funny it's just
funny at every single step of the way
but it
it's a
in being so hilarious which is what I'm
looking for in these kinds of comedies
it actually gets across a message that
is pretty
conservative and normal and true if you
took out all of the individual vulgar
elements and you just replace them with
a wholesome alternative then the story
of the movie would be
would be very very conservative would be
very Trad but it's it's so funny it's
it's it's Jim Carrey's best work by far
just I just love it boy what a great
clip that was now
you gotta ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael Knowles YouTube show Channel
program
Comedy Hour we'll see you next time